وصلنا مشاهدينا الى فقرتنا الجديده التي
نبداها اليوم قيل في الامثال تتشابه طبعا
امثالنا العربيه من الخليج للمحيط وان
اختلفت البلدان عادل المثل المنطوق
باللهجه المصريه يوازي اخر بمعنى نفسه لكن
باللهجه التونسيه او بسوريه او حتى يمكن
الخليجيه اكيد طبعا احنا الان رح نلعب
لعبه مشاهدينا لعبه تفاعليه
اطلقنا قيل في الامثال راح يشاركنا فيها
المراسلان او مراسلينا عبد الرحمن العصيمي
ان السعوديه وعماد العضايله من الاردن
اهلا وسهلا فيكم القاعد اه اليوم
باللباس الرسمي
عماد
على فكره ترى اول مره اشوف عماد بهذا
الشكل هذا خليني وانا كمان والله يا عبد
الرحمن ليتك تشوفه طيب خلينا نقول نبدا
بعماد بمثل اردني اللعبه كما هي انجاز
التعبير وراعي المثل ما خلى شيء ما قاله
احنا دائما نقولها عماد يبدا بمثل اردني
وبعدين يرد عليه عبد الرحمن بالمرادف من
الامثال السعوديه والعكس صحيح تحدي بينهم
نشوف مين راح يكسب واللي شنو اللي يرفع
الرايه البيضاء يخسر
بس احنا قبل ما نبلش معاهم لحظه شوي احنا
صباح الخير طبعا لحظه يا عماد عندها شيء
ما ادري
نروح لحرب الامثال هاي بدينا نعمل هيك حرب
امثال بيني وبينك شوي والله ماني قوي
على فكره بس فعلا انا يعني العجيب في
الموضوع والمثير لهالاهتمام الرائع بانه
قديش التجربه الانسانيه مشتركه ومتشابهه
والناس بتوصل لنفس الفلسفه الفطريه
احنا مثلا عندنا الشيء او الشخص اللي
العجل اللي يجهز الشيء قبل وقوع البلاء او
الحادثه مثلا نقول يزهب الدول الدواء قبل
الفلع الفلعه اللي مثلا الشق بالراس انه
ايه قبل
اشي قبل الهنا بسنه قبل الهنا بسنه زين ما
يعرفك عن منبوعه دلاله على انه سالم
بفلسطين نفس المثل الكعب
مش فاهم وين الله حاطه طيب
العصيمي روح
العضايله رمى القفاز في ملعبك رد عليه
طيب يلا احنا احنا حنبدا اول شيء
المثل الاول عندنا في السعوديه مثل داريت
جدا الحي يحيك والميت يزيدك يقال اذا
صديقك عندك صديق متفائل ونشيط وعندك
بمقابل واحد كئيب
الميت يزيدك لا يا عماد روح عمده عنا
بالاردن بيقول رافقي السعيد تسعد عنا
بالاردن بنقول رفع رافق السعيد تسعد
ورافقه تعيس تتعس هذا ردا على مثل
عبد الرحمن العصيمي ويا عبد الرحمن انا
بقول لك انا اللي فائز وانا راح افوز انه
مالك حيلي معي لانه احنا كل يعني الامس
بدي اعطيه انا طبعا الامثال كثيره كاتبهم
عندي بصراحه لكن بدي اعطيه مثل بقول
قول قول
يلا قول يا عماد
انا بقول لعبد الرحمن ما بفهم رطني غير
ابن بطني بس خلينا نوضح الرطن ترى الرطن
هو الكلام هو الكلام غير المفهوم الرقم
والكلام نعم او الحديث باع جميع
او بالعاميه هاي عبد الرحمن ما يعرفني انا
تعبت
هل مثل هذا تعبني صراحه شوي ما قدرت
القاله بس لقيت له شيء مشابه تقريبا
ما يحك جلدك الا ظفرك
قابل يا عماد يعني شفنا ما له علاقه
بصراحه ما له علاقه مثل مثل مثل عبد
الرحمن ماله علاقه قوي صراحه المثل الثاني
هذا هذا هذه المره جوله العصيمي روح يا
عبد الرحمن
قبل ما نروح على عبد الرحمن العصيمي انا
بدي اقول كلمتين احكي كلمتين لعبد الرحمن
العصيمي مو كل من صفي الصواني صار حلواني
ومو كل من وقف قدام عماد العضايلي
بالامثال صار شاعر اوه الله الله لا قويه
قويه لا لا لا لا هذا
هذا تصعيد غير مبرر والله لكن عموما عبد
الرحمن عبد الرحمن قلبي معاك بس رد عليه
ما تخليه انا جاي اهدي النفوس ما واضح يلا
يلا
واضح جدا مثل يقول يا عادل ويا عماد ويا
ما كل ابيض شحم وماكل اسود فحم
ها يا عماد حلو حلو هذا عباد قاعد تذاكر
انت ولا يعني لحظه لحظه
بعتقد انه
ان شاء الله لا انا اللي عندي بيني وبينك
انا يعني المشكله عندي الذاكره فانا بحاول
يعني
برد عليه
ههه
المثل اللي قاله عبد الرحمن بيرد عليه
بقول من برا هالله هالله ومن جوا يعلم
الله يلا هات يا
صفاء وياك يلا رد
انا انا مستمتعه بهذا السجال اصلا
عماد عطله عصيمي مثل يلا دورك يلا اعطيني
اعطيني يا عماد مثل ثاني من امثال اللي
موجود
طيب عند عند عند
شغيلي عند شغيلي فهد حيلي عفوا
لا لا هذه هذه عشره صفر حق عبد الرحمن
العصيمي لا لا يعني كاتبها وبحضرها لا لا
بس انا انا بصراحه بصراحه والله لا بس
باقي
عند الصخره مثل المهره وعندك غيري بها
تحيلي او برد حيلي يلا يا عبد الرحمن
بالضبط هذا مقابل وعندنا في السعوديه يا
عماد
الزوجه لما تروح عند اهلها وما تشتغل وعند
بيت زوجها تشتغل شو يقولون لها عنده هيلي
ما حيل وعندي رجالي
شباب هاي كمان واحد من عندي ليش لانه اللي
عند اهله على مهله
صح
يلا يا عبد الرحمن اخر مثلا عندك خذ هذه
عبد الرحمن يلا خذ هذه يا عماد يقول وحنا
في جده الان جده البلد وجده ومره خاوي
الشده فعنقول لكم مثل حجازي يقول قرصه في
ناره
وعينه على جاره هذا يقال للطماع
اللي ما يقتنع هذه اعضاء عبد الرحمن عطاك
المثل يا عماد ردها ان استطعت
احنا عنا ابسط من هيك احنا بنقول عينه على
اللي يفيد غيره
عينه على اللي في ايد بسيط جدا بس نفس
المعنى والله المثل السعودي
غيره
قواكم الله شكرا جزيلا عبد الرحمن انا
اهنيك على الفوز باخذها مني انت فايز بس
عماد العضايله كسب قلوب دقيقه دقيقه كيف
كيف فوته ليش فوزته ما انت انت ليش فوزته
انا عندي عندي 500 مثلا انا قاعد عبد
الرحمن بس خلني عماد عماد بس خلني اعترف
اول مره اشوف برشامه الكبر يعني واحد يغش
من صفحتين اي 4 مو برشامه هاي هاي يلونها
برشامه هاي لونها برشامه ماشي ههه
طب انا بدي احكي اخر مثل بصير يلا قول بدي
احكي اخر مثل بتحكموا عليه بعد ذلك شو
رايك قولي
لما كان كرمي يا كثر احبابي لما كان كرمي
دبس وياقل احبابي يوم كارميه بس خلي عبد
الرحمن يرد علي ان استطاع سريع عبد الرحمن
خلصنا
في بيت شعر للامير خالد الفيصل الشاعر
الكبير يقول دورت بالشده حزام ولا لقيت
اللي جوه يا الله دخيلك ما لقيت اللي نشد
بهالظهر الله صح لسانك صح لسان الله الله
الله معناته
[موسيقى]
هيك انا بعترف انه عبد الرحمن هو اللي
فائز
بعترف انه عبد الرحمن هو الفائز بعد هذا
بيت الشعر هذا اللي يتحدث فيه يلا احنا
اللي فايزين بانه كسبناكم وكسبنا
هالابتسامه الجميله والجوه الطيبه من
الصبح شكرا جزيلا
انا اللي فايز طبعا انا اللي قاعد حياك
الله لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات